les amis vous avez vu ces images c'était
hier et place vendôme célèbre marque
devient quand ryan braqué regarde des
images c'est absolument à me dire que
j'avais vu
les gars ça c'est un braquage
5,5 fokine braquage légasse un braque
chicha des livres je suis garé
je crois qu'on le plaigne
alors c'est la célèbre marque de
vêtements c'est donc chez arm bijoux ont
été dérobés pour un montant de 3
millions de la meinau ils ont pris la
fuite à moto c'est des images après ça a
pris quoi s'applique 1 seconde non non
exactement quatre minutes une
15,4 à 4 minutes je vous assure 4 4
minutes oui je me suis intéressé à cette
affaire parce que c'est dingue en plein
jour il était 15h de l'après midi c'est
incroyable d'avoir fait ça aussi
rapidement et bex est alors ils avaient
d'exa rebond s'est passé était fausse ou
pas des ak 47
ouais c'est en gamme des fusils
mitrailleurs on sait pas si c'était faux
et dassault oui mais c'est que oui et
mais moi je ne veux pas être un indic de
police mais j'ai l'impression qu'il ya
du jeu reconnaît de gens de ton et ben
on est des infos sur l'anc est tout
simplement un poteau will et ils sont
toujours introuvables la police essaie
de donner de les retrouver donc ils
étaient quatre cd professionnel a priori
c'est un mode de para professionnel il y
avait quinze caméras dans la boutique
chanel mais impossible de les deux lors
qu'on est français mais les plaques
étaient fausses les plaques
alors le nom l'adresse
est ce qu'on peut dire c'est que c'est
assez incroyable parce que moi
j'applaudis des deux mains parce que le
service de com de shannen il est quand
même très très efficace au même moment
exactement au même moment à monte carlo
à monaco avait lieu le fameux défilé
chanel à le défilé croisière donc pour
le coup ils ont raflé la place de
quasiment tous les magazines et par la
ce de la maison chanel est ce que l'on
peut dire également
commencer d'ici c'est génial pour le
commun dire qu'ils sont particulièrement
bien informé parce qu on sait qu avait
déjà énormément de joyaux plus qu'à
l'habitude puisque ils sont ils vont par
et les stars pour le festival de cannes
et a notamment a été dérobé une paire de
boucles d'oreilles énorme que devait
porter diane kruger elle ne les prag
rigueur a absolument et a été dérobée
également ce qu'on avoir largué voie
lactée le collier voie lactée c'est une
création des années 30 que gabrielle
chanel avait imaginé lorsqu'elle est
sortie avec le duc de willem des fois
c'est quand même des pièces ça se forme
pas saoul mais voilà alors comment est
ce qu'ils vont faire pour alors
justement qui doivent retail et les
diamants ainsi pas pas du tout vendre
dans les tailles vais d'ailleurs
personne ils vont effacer tout ce qui
est en hausse et marquer parce que dia
le sigle chainel sur tous les jours en
or donc il va être obligé de tout
refondre sa et le fossé classique
au prix de l'or par exemple ils ont
piqué démontre à 200 mille balles ils
vont les vendre 100 millions 30 machin
rien quoi faire et moi d'ailleurs il ya
peut-être
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça fait quand même froid dans le dos
parce qu'il y avait quelqu'un un des
quatre faisait le gué avec une arme on
ne sait pas encore si elle est vraie ou
fausse messieurs rien si une voiture de
police était arrivée à ce moment là on
va plus être un carnage il aurait
peut-être tiré donc ça fait quand même
froid dans le dos et moi ce qui me fait
peur c'est le monsieur qui a filmé le
jeune homme qui se fait appeler john je
sais pas si on l'a vu doigt sur il se
montre sur une chaîne et on sait
maintenant qu'on a la plaque
d'immatriculation grâce à lui donc moi
je suis
pour ce
plateau pour que les mecs des vraies
plaques d'immatriculation
on en rigole mais faut quand même penser
à ccpo vendeuse qu'ils avaient
traumatisé
le garde aussi parce que je suis tu
avais un garde mmg à l'intérieur c'est
quelque chose qui doit être tellement
dur à vivre et puis en plein coeur de
paris comme ça pour le tourisme c'est
pas bon non plus l'image que ça alors je
vous et moi j'ai des amis qui ont des
bijouteries la consigne pour les
employés c'est simple le maintien
d'objectifs de braquer chez vous donne
tout et des assurances pour ça et aucun
et boka mais voilà donc c'est d'ailleurs
les braqueurs le savent très bien se
montrer peu de temps benjamin comment
quatre minutes ce quand même langue
quatre minutes comment quatre minutes à
l'endroit où se trouve cette boutique
n'est pas quand même chez pas des
voitures de police car j'adore vous
aideront braquage vous le dis c'est
toujours au centre de paris et
paradoxalement c'est là où il ya le il
ya moins de diamants et moins de ronde
au
ministère de la justice
et rue de la paix c'est oui ça saigne
avons quand même en vacances riches